best bit of a chef's favorite because
it's absolutely full of flavor gave me
very rich and the texture is
extraordinary score don't go all the way
through just the layer of fat
Szechuan pepper lightly roast them in a
dry pan
the smell is amazing
season grind rub almost like you're
massaging and this is one of the most
amazing seasonings in Chinese cooking
and makes the Ducks very aromatic
mop it up into a dry pan on a low heat
slowly cook gooseberry sauce sugar water
lemon zest boil
gooseberries you've got that swing sound
hanging us against the rich sumptuous of
the duck was delicious just bring back
up the ball and take off the heat and
set aside
season
now it's reduced down to a really nice
syrup and that gives us nice shine to
the sauce
and starts to give it some bother
chicken stock reduce that's the basic
method of making a sauce in all a
kitchens goose reason
honey get your spoon put into the sauce
and wash a nice hot spoon how easy it
drops off
butter take off the heat and just shake
look at that gloss very velvety
beautiful goopy source that's ready to
go
come to the duck turn up the heat start
coloring the duck the nice thing about
the Szechuan pepper now is starting to
smell slightly sweeter and it's becoming
a lot more aromatic fat side down into
the oven hot oven 10 minutes now the
smell is amazing three or four slices
maximum
onto the plate and delays
those gooseberries are just nice and
soft and plump can you Kimmie Kimmie
dealt with gooseberry sauce done the
crispy topping you can think what that
deserves to be a great British classic
that has to be the perfect strong enough
smoked paprika chicken stroganoff bits
pet silly